hi I'm Zoe and I'm going to tell you how
to break the internet so when your
computer wants to see a web page it
sends a message through a network of
routers to a server and the server sends
a web page back through the same network
each router is a small computer which
has enough information about the network
that it can direct your message along
the shortest path possible routers know
what the network looks like because they
advertise to each other about their
connections so for example router a
could advertise that it has a path of
length 2 to server why it sends this
advertisement to router be and because
router be already knows that it has a
path length of 1 to router a now router
be knows that it has a path length of 32
server why the caches there's nothing
stopping these routers from lying to
each other so a could advertise it it
has a connection of length negative 10
to server why and now be thinks that it
has a connection of like negative 92
server y and this false message
propagates throughout the network so all
the traffic that should be going to
server why is now passing through router
a so if router a is malicious it could
choose to take all this traffic and just
drop it so the cool thing is this
actually happened in real life a few
years ago the Pakistani government
decided it didn't want its citizens to
access YouTube so just like router a it
sent out a false advertisement claiming
to have a really short path the YouTube
servers so whenever a Pakistani citizen
tried to access YouTube their request
got sent to the government instead or it
was dropped and on accident this
advertisement actually spread beyond
Pakistan and so for several hours large
parts of the world were unable to access
YouTube so this is one way that you
could actually break the internet